welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Rick and Morty season four has
consistently shown one commonality among
its three episodes thus far a real
faulty turn for Morty even before the
season began many of us have been
theorizing that the Morty we've been
following could gradually be
transforming into evil Morty and 401 402
403 all appear to be following that
darkest timeline in this week's episode
of Rick's plane since we all have a week
off from new episodes I'm gonna look
back at the ways these past three
episodes have shown a dark shift for
Morty with some evidence more subtle
than other pieces of evidence that could
be sitting up the rise of evil Morty and
joining us later this episode will be
some special guests who discuss this
season so far
Wow I would argue that this whole series
has been a slow downward slide for Morty
into a pit of cynicism and nihilism like
the kind express constantly by Rick
these past three episodes have
definitely knocked that transition into
12th gear in the season four premiere
Morty uses the death crystals to glimpse
at various possible futures through a
kaleidoscopic lens each one horrible and
violent but one just one is peaceful and
loving with elderly Jessica at his
bedside Morty without hesitation gives
up his soul to pursue that destiny he
kills his grandpa he refuses to
resurrect them he beats up some bullies
bullies that are still missing you tears
police and armies into pieces and turns
himself into a Tetsuo style blob but in
a depressing twist in the post-credits
scene that one hopeful future is
revealed to be a lie I would have
comfort the people who are dying who
have no one else in their lives
the real only people I'm gonna look at
their name tags and I'm gonna say I love
you followed by whatever it says other
name tag over and over what Maury slams
his locker and anger and if you look at
the inside of that locker it's it's
photo of Jessica he gives up he's done
trying he knows there's no happy ending
for him episode 2 is more of a Rick
episode dealing with his loneliness but
in the B story of that episode
Morty accompanies his father Jerry as he
tries to launch a dating app with blue
Dee and Morty delivers to his father's
face a very savage line yet I want to
say something
I started today disgusted and
embarrassed to be your son and then
later I thought we were gonna die
because you're a loser
there's no more let's go him okay I mean
Morty obviously lost respect for his
father long before this but at least he
would try to show him respect to his
face now he talks to him with the cruel
honesty exactly like Rick would I think
a blind man conceded Beth is looking for
the door I barely have a reason to care
and even I notice come on Rick don't
talk about my parents like that
defensive idealistic Morty from season 1
gone and that brings us to episode 3 in
which Morty's latest project his dreams
of becoming a Hollywood screenwriter get
shattered when Rick Incept the idea in
his mind that heist movies are lame as
he pitches his movie the Netflix you can
actually pinpoint the second when his
heart rips in half Morty is seen from
the bottom of his water bottle drowning
in his own fatalistic outlook and the
final scene Morty's engaged in the
pointless exercises of a Rubik's Cube
what pointless depend on who you ask but
it is the one kind of tourists that he
now considers worthwhile dark storm
clouds form on the horizon which is
interesting because it matches these
storm clouds that formed over Rick in
the previous episode what does this tell
us about Morty's state of mind what does
it tell us about the darkness in store
for him would he be headed to a fate in
which he uses an eyepatch sometimes to
control a Rick drone I wouldn't say
Morty would be capable of that in season
1 but I could definitely see it now for
this morning to be the same evil Morty
we've seen thus far it wouldn't really
require time-travel because that is
something that the writers have always
avoided some multiverse timelines are
farther along than others like how the
Citadel contain that older veteran Morty
cop and then the pilot Rick did hop to a
future where medicine existed that could
instantaneously fix Morty's legs it's
also possible that all Morty's in all
realities exist on arcs that inevitably
lead them to become evil Morty's due to
exposure to their Rick's next week
episode force titled claw and hoarder
special victims Morty a play on Law &
Order SVU
but the promo for the episode showed
Rick entering a fantasy quest involving
a dragon that's the end of the Dragon
episode are you gonna say it first off I
always slay it Queen secondly
Julieta prepared better for this
terrifying battle by remembering the
only thing dragons are not for this
dragon seems like a take on Smaug from
The Hobbit we haven't seen many fantasy
tropes and sorcerer jokes in Rick and
Morty but it is something that Dan
Harmon has always been into with his D&D
animated series Harmon quest if dandy is
an inspiration for this episode I'll be
very curious to see if alignment comes
up alignment refers to the categories of
a character's morality on scales of good
versus evil and waffle versus chaotic
I've seen a number of fan-made Rick and
Morty alignment charts over the years
most plays Rick's somewhere around
chaotic neutral and chaotic evil meaning
he's completely anti lawful
anti-regulation of any kind but it's not
clear whether he's immoral or amoral
meanwhile Morty has been a big rule
follower but it's not for debate whether
he's a lawful good or lawful neutral and
evil Morty is definitely a lawful evil
so how far has our morty slid down that
lawful column will discuss Morty's moral
alignment in season 4 with some special
guests after a quick message from our
sponsors hey guys have you ever tried to
buy cologne for yourself and you're so
lost and stinky that the department
store Santa tackles you and rubs candy
canes on your armpits it's a very real
scenario and you should be fearful of it
smelling good is important and that's
why I love Hawthorne instead of smelling
a bunch of cents and frying your
nostrils Hawthorne has you take a short
quiz about your lifestyle and
preferences whatever weird way you live
your life and then they send you two
cents one for work one for play I love
this handy quiz it's got a scale for Bo
that goes from no Bo too painful Bo
painful is the operative word because
when those candy canes crack they turn
into ships they also have deodorant
shampoo and body wash I personally loved
the body wash they sent me the bottle
just says body wash very literal for a
dummy like me because showers make me
stupid but now thanks to Hawthorne
showers make me smell a lot better too
the whole quiz process is easy and so
convenient best of all it's totally
risk-free with free shipping and free
returns
check out Hawthorne yourself at
Hawthorne SEO that's Hawthorne with an E
use my promo code Ric to get 10% off
your first purchase
that's hawgtv my code Ric to get 10% off
your purchase Hawthorne dot Co this
episode of explain was also brought to
you by helix sleep sometimes when I'm up
late going frame by frame through the
corrosion of mortise conscience I forget
that horizontal sleep it's something
human beings need to recharge
helix mattress is exactly what I need to
get that restful slumber so I don't turn
into a zombie and murder all of you just
go to helix sleep comm /r explained take
their 2 minutes sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life whether you're a side sleeper hot
sleeper if you like a plush or firm bed
with helix there's no more confusion no
more compromising on an average mattress
helix sleep was awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2019 by GQ
& Wired magazine they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free believe it pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
you will love it helix is offering up to
$200 off all mattress orders for our
listeners at helix sleep calm slasher
explained that's helix h e li
for up to $200 off and we are back in to
talk about this season of Rick and Morty
the first three episodes so far as we're
in this break week we have some
wonderful guests here joining us
recurring voice actor on the show echo
Kellum thank you for joining us great
and Tommy Beck holds back for more echo
we've heard your voice since season 1
you voiced a Brad that's Jessica's
ex-boyfriend new voice Jacob who is the
Gary's parents caretaker
yeah caretaker / lover we've heard your
voice in the love finders episode you
did assorted voices of different people
who were getting randomly yeah yes i I'm
curious because we've never had like a
voice actor on the show here before to
kind of explain that process yeah what
it what is it like being brought into
the show like just kind of walk us
through yes so so originally I got the
audition from voiceover agent and then
women and we recorded it and then we
sent it out and usually you know you do
so many of those and you just never
anything back like well you know just
gone like put it out and then they
really like my read for it so then I got
called in and I met Justin roiland who's
amazing and you know we did we messed
around with voices a little bits like
that and we're not just like gel
old just like instantly and then they
called me was like what you'd play these
couple roles in the show and so then
with that basically you know I would
come in to starburns industries and then
they would put me in a sound booth we
talk about the character a little bit he
might have some animatics just very
early rough sketches of them and whatnot
and they read with you the other lines
and then you read with them and they
record it and you know sometimes it
takes a couple different takes you know
four or five takes and sometimes I'll
have you read the line and they repeat
it three times and just do it a couple
different ways to give them just you
know options and things like that and
then you get it and then they lock it
hopefully and then it gets seen on TV
and then you all animating it's
interesting to hear that they're like
reading with you because a lot of times
in voiceover you are just alone in a
booth yeah engineers yeah it sounds like
you were saying before that Justin's
super handy Justin is there for every
facet every moment like he is super
hands-on so it's usually him that you're
working with and in every capacity I
mean he's like there morning noon and
night just like giving his odds of the
show so he's the one who's usually
reading with you too so it's like you
actually have Rick employee like right
there yeah doing other characters and
he's like so talented his voiceover I do
it's like really cool just that he's
like very talented but also one of the
most humble kind
I've ever met like it just welcoming
open just like such a great guy you know
it's crazy like he voices the two main
characters and like several other
characters you have like basically the
whole world of the show in the room with
you guys like the Simpsons like a lot of
those actors live in completely
different cities hundred percent he just
mail it he's like the Matt Groening yeah
and he's like the Seth MacFarlane little
bit like Homer and you know I'm Sam bar
you know a lot of ways you know it's
it's is really a testament to his love
of the show his work ethic and just you
know how passionate he is about it you
know and in that it definitely bleeds
over until I think everything else that
goes on with it all the other actors
like we all want to give like our best
funniest takes and just like give as
much as he does even a slither or I out
of what he gives and yeah you know I
think that's what makes the show as
great as it is yeah we all met doing
improvin yeah la Canne yeah we did yeah
and I'm curious like on some shows they
want you to stick very close to the
script when you're in the booth how much
do they let you ad-lib or improvised
with the loads it just depends on the
specific lines you know sometimes some
of the lines have to track with the
story or whatnot but I think generally
they let you play around after you get
it like they let you play around add a
little bit more if you can or if you
want if you have to trust there to you
know I'm saying they're knowing that
it's not going off into some crazy
tangent and whatnot yeah I think you
have to be surgical about the improv you
add into episodic television I usually
have been like surgical when I try to
add thing I try to add things to
complement the writing not to detract
from the writing so I think if you once
you build that type of rapport and it
just lets you play but he's very much
like he is an artist producer an artist
director you know he definitely trust
the artist that he works with and he
loves to get out as much from them as
much as he puts in so when you say
surgical when you're when you're going
to record do you have any kind of
concept of what it's going to visually
look like or is it easier to not know
that because that way you will feel free
to add in a thing or two knowing that
it's not getting to a different frame or
different scene right see if they're
already kind of deeper into the
animatics of it then you know you're
kinda in a more structured bubble of
what you can use but if it's pretty
early on you do have that freedom to
like play with it more and they'll build
around your at libs and whatnot -
they'll like make the the words make
sense and build the animation to
progress that out if it's a longer you
know ad lib or whatnot so it definitely
depends on stages for sure sometimes but
you know sometimes I have you come in to
pick up a part that they missed that
would help the story flow better with
the character and so you just have to be
a menial and kind of adjust on the fly
with them and just you know go in and
just rock it up very cool yeah
did you how do you have any like
specific ad-lib said you remember
throwing in there even if they didn't
make the episode oh man that's so tough
you know it's like even the stuff that
people are hearing now and season four
like I may be shot that like eight
months ago or like so it's just stuff
like and then like all my other stuff
those years ago it's really tough to
think about a specific room I would add
in there and I need to watch it more I
love the line
I quit I'm gay and I love Xander that
was definitely right now where's that I
love that words are funny the way it's
listed off as a to-do list we watch that
episode together Eric and I and that
part was definitely highlight I quit I'm
gay and I love Xander I think that's
really like it just shows you how great
of a director Justin is you know with
all this like the things they can get
out of actors you know the different
ways like he always has such amazing
ideas like to say like this what do you
what have you said with this type of
emotion or what if he like he just
really plays with you in there and I
think that's once again it's a testament
to why the show is amazing it is yeah
it's so many performances yeah I wonder
if there is interesting the parallels
between early seasons of Family Guy
where Seth MacFarlane was really kind of
the way you're describing Justin seems
to be the stories of how he was where he
was super hands-on yes totally his baby
and he kind of willed it from its
original incarnation and then
cancellation and then brought back it
was kind of a labor of love and the
quality of the show seems like people
really adore those faces and Rick and
Morty is when those things where the fan
trip is so strong and so passionate and
I wonder if it's because there's the
authentic drive of a creator like Justin
that's just like every part of him is
going it's all over the show but you
can't there's no I mean obviously
there's Dan Harmon's genius yeah but
it's like that show has his fingerprints
on almost every all absolutely and Dan
harm is definitely a big part of that
too you know I mean he obviously is when
I think one of the comedic geniuses of
our time communities one of my favorite
shows ever I mean he did the show on vh1
years ago him and Justin call acceptable
TV right that I would watch over and
over again when they canceled to almost
cry because I was like no it was too
good it was kind of like a spinoff of
their kind of channel 101 series do they
do in LA yeah it was so phenomenal so
even when I got the opportunity to
finally work with Justin like I was
already huge fans of theirs you know so
I was like so dope that he thought I was
funny - it was like I'm a fan of yours I
want to work with you
but you know I think them together like
Justin obviously being hands-on and
being like in the trenches every single
day definitely makes the show freakin
amazing having Dan's comedic genius and
aspects behind all the writing and
what's going on what it definitely makes
it amazing them together it's like a
super team you know and so they really
are each other's I feel yin and yang
especially to just create it's the
really brilliant material that we all
get the pleasure to get to share it yeah
on this show we've kind of speculated
how like there's definitely a parallel
between Justin and Dan's relationship
and Rick and Morty's really write their
partnership there one great thing that
should not exist but because like they
perfectly complement each other we now
this wonderful thing and you were jokey
before we started recording how would
like is it Ricky Morty or is it Morty
and Rick right like in the earlier part
of this episode when no one was here is
by myself hi guys one of my theory that
like these three episodes of season four
we're seeing we're starting to see the
decline of Morty's morality and he has
become a more Rick like and there is
less of a distinction between them
they're both just kind of like just in
cynical voice through the lens of these
characters do you think that like by the
end of the show we might be headed in a
direction where they could reverse yeah
and Morty's the more Morty's the more
Rick and we have more than more I mean
the thing about this shows I think
anything is possible like fake I mean
literally the characters killed
themselves and came back you know you
never know what's gonna happen so I
definitely can see a world where Morty
can be that kind of negative influence
on Rick and kind of those juxtapositions
can definitely switch I mean I think
that probably definitely this season
feels like it's going to that trajectory
yeah but so I think it's 100% possible
it's probably just a matter of when and
not it yeah yeah it's it's and I think
that's one way cuz there is a precious
sacred balance to that and I don't want
like because the characters do have to
evolve over the course of a series
people change that's what makes them
interesting to watch but like I don't
want them both to be cynical or both
them to be realistic right i if there is
gonna be status shift I hope they both
shift in the opposite way right right
yeah yeah we'll see well thanks so much
for coming on thanks for having me on a
chat like this is so great to have you
on to catch up and
see everything that you're doing do you
have anything you want to shout out that
you want to what I want to shout out I
do have music that I'm gonna be released
in a new year so I'm excited about that
I'll have links and everything on my
Instagram echo Kells or Twitter a tech
okay um yeah that's that's alright great
yeah Tommy you get to pitch enough okay
[Laughter]
well thanks so much for joining us in
this episode of her explained we'll be
back next week to break down episode 4
as always we're also doing like the
easter-egg breakdowns of every episode
you can find us at new rock stars on all
social media and on YouTube and make
sure to subscribe to us where we gear
podcasts a tricks planed to get us
higher in those charts the attention
must be paid we're doing good work here
I'm proud of us a lot of stuff happening
behind the scenes to make this happen so
thanks again for joining us and let's
close out with a highlight reel of some
of echos great vocal work on the show I
throw balls far you want good words
date and language Jerry this Ham has got
to be all you right it's incredible I'm
half Abraham Lincoln so so I should get
on my knees and kiss ya know but you
know what do I know that the Third Reich
will reign for a thousand years alone
brassicas aspirin kick his ass
[Music]